et on va voir dans le discours de Gérard
lâcher dans quelques secondes mais aussi
dans le discours de rusland Stéphane
chouk et bien c'est comment ce volet du
dossier entre la France et l'Ukraine est
abordé aujourd'hui à la chambre haute du
parlement plus qui était hier en visite
à Matignon qui était aussi en visite à
l'Elysée ainsi qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale et qui termine donc sa visite
officielle ici au Sénat je vous propose
de nous rendre dans l'hémicycle pour
écouter ses discours sur notre antenne
en intégralité on se retrouve juste
après
vers cette séance solennelle on disait
une séance inédite une séance historique
je vous le redisais ça fait 20 ans qu'on
n'a pas eu un président de chambre
parlementaire qui tient un discours à la
tribune du Sénat la cloche a sonné
direction l'hémicycle
monsieur le président
de la Rada
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs mes
chers collègues
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur du crâne en
France
la guerre
il y a un an presque jour pour jour
mes chers collègues
ce mot terrible que l'on croyait banni
du continent européen
a résonné à nouveau en Europe
il ne s'agit pas d'une guerre
allégorique
de celle que l'on déclare de façon
parfois galvaudée dans une situation
d'adversité
il s'agit bien d'une guerre réelle d'une
guerre d'agression dans toute sa
brutalité
à vrai dire
la guerre n'était pas nouvelle
en ce 24 février 2022
votre peuple monsieur le Président de la
Rada
connaît la guerre depuis 2014
depuis l'agression de la Russie et
l'occupation d'une partie de l'Ukraine
9 années déjà même si ces derniers mois
furent d'une intensité rarement égalée
ce qui a changé
à partir du 24 février 2022
ce fut la mobilisation inédite des
soutiens de l'Ukraine dans le monde au
sein de l'Union européenne et en France
depuis le sommet de l'État jusqu'au
simple citoyen sans oublier nos
collectivités territoriales
car il faut le reconnaître avec lucidité
en 2014 et dans les années qui suivirent
à l'exception des
Ukrainiens agressés et de quelques pays
européens
nous n'avions pas pris collectivement
vraiment la mesure de ceux qui se
produisait sur le sol de l'Ukraine
et du danger représenté par
l'impérialisme russe
ce passé
fait des résolutions et désormais
derrière nous
votre cause est devenue la nôtre
parce que nous savons que l'Union
européenne ne sera pas en paix si la
Russie était victorieuse en Ukraine
nous avons qu'un objectif et un seul
que demain l'Ukraine soit libéré
la fermeture de l'engagement des pays
vous soutenant dans la France fait ses
preuves
la décision de livraison de char à
mx-10rc par notre pays comme celle
desquels on César puis la décision de
livraison de Charlot par d'autres États
ont constitué un tournant supplémentaire
dans la détermination collective à vous
soutenir
cet engagement est appelé à perdurer et
à ne pas faiblir nous formons le vœu que
la France dans le cadre d'une aide
militaire cohérente
concertée avec ses partenaires
continuent d'apporter une contribution
substantielle à votre système de défense
pour mieux protéger les populations
civiles et vous installations
stratégiques et vous aider à résister et
à reconquérir le territoire de l'Ukraine
internationalement reconnu
risque d'escalade
en tentant
cette interrogation légitime mais quelle
est l'alternative laissée par la Russie
ce n'est pas l'Ukraine qui nous
contraint à livrer toujours plus de
matériel c'est la poursuite de
l'agression et les exections Russes qui
nous l'imposent
la France et l'Union européenne
à la différence de l'Ukraine ne sont pas
en guerre
contre la Russie mais les autorités
russes sont bel et bien désignés comme
leur adversaire et je cite l'Occident
c'est leur propre terme
quand ces circonstances
l'Ukraine doit non seulement être en
capacité de résister mais aussi de
prendre
l'avantage stratégique nous devons y
aider
monsieur le président
il y a six mois en juillet 2022
vous m'avez accueilli ainsi qu'une
délégation de sénateurs dans l'enceinte
de la Rada
et vous m'avez donné l'occasion de
prononcer un discours en séance plénière
devant tous les parlementaires
peut-on se figurer un Parlement réuni
régulièrement mes chers collègues sous
la menace permanente des alertes à
l'approche de missile destructeur
quel est le quotidien de nos collègues
parlementaires de la radar
en résistant
les Ukrainiens démontrent que l'héroïsme
n'est pas la vertu des causes des
espérer
ce soit être mes chers collègues que cet
instant nous nous levions pour rendre
hommage au courage de nos collègues
parlementaires de la Rada à l'instar de
tous les ukrainiens et que nous les
applaudissions
[Applaudissements]
le 7 février
le Sénat débattra d'un projet de
résolution en soutien à votre pays
qui dépasse les clivage politique et je
l'espère recueillera les plus larges
suffrages
le projet de résolution ne se contente
pas de répéter les résolutions
précédentes il fait chien le plan de P
présenté par le président zenenski lors
du sommet du G20 le 15 novembre 2022
la souveraineté de l'Ukraine sur
l'ensemble de son territoire n'est pas
négociable la Crimée ou le don de basse
n'ont qu'une vocation être
ukrainien
surtout le projet de résolution du Sénat
ainsi sur l'impératif de justice afin
que les criminels qui au nom de la
Russie commettent des exactions et des
crimes de guerre qui persécutent qui
exécutent des civils sachent ils ne
bénéficieront d'aucune impunité parce
que l'impunité ouvre la voie au plus
grand crime et à la manipulation de
l'histoire en témoigne la négation
persistante par les autorités russes de
ce qui conviendrait de reconnaître comme
le génocide de Lolo de mort en 1932 et
monsieur le Président de la radio
ukrainienne mes chers collègues
sénateurs
le moment
que nous partageons aujourd'hui est
exceptionnel
sinon inédit si le président zenachi
s'est exprimé le 23 mars en
visio-conférence devant le Parlement
français
jamais les missiles du Sénat a accueilli
le président du Parlement d'un pays en
guerre
et cela a fait même plus de 20 ans
c'était en 2003 qu'aucun président d'une
assemblée d'un pays étranger que s'est
exprimé à la tribune ce qui sera votre
cas dans quelques instants monsieur le
président
le président du bundeslament et la
présidente du Parlement européen ont eu
par le passé cette opportunité c'est
bien la dimension européenne qui est
conforme qui est en ce moment conféré à
cette tribune c'est dire le degré
d'amitié de confiance que le Sénat
témoigne à la radar et à son président
oui vraiment vive l'Ukraine vive la
république et vive la France
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]